-Mother's Day is this weekend,
and with today being
Teacher Appreciation Day,
we wanted to do something --
[ Cheers and applause ]
...special
in honor of that.
So we teamed up with Samsung
to surprise some amazing
moms out there,
moms who are also teachers.
And we brought them to
New York
and told them that they were
going to appear
in a Mother's Day special
to air on NBC.
What they didn't know is that
I was hiding nearby
and about to surprise them
with a very special
Mother's Day gift from Samsung.
Check this out.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
-Hi, my name is Susan.
I'm here to talk about
my wonderful friend,
teacher-mom extraordinaire,
Joanne.
She teaches high school on the
Upper East Side in Manhattan.
She grew up in the Philippines,
and she didn't have
a lot of money growing up,
and I think that that's sort of
what makes her who she is.
She wants to give back.
Joanne is someone who
doesn't' believe that
teaching and learning
stays in a classroom.
She's always bringing
her kids out into the world.
Somehow, in between all of that,
she's the mom that keeps
all of our friends together.
And she always just makes us
feel super loved.
-My amazing mother is a teacher
and a wonderful mom.
My mother immigrated
to the United States
close to 40 years ago.
Throughout my mom's career
as an educator,
she has helped many children.
Her drive is working with
students who have immigrated
from other countries,
inspiring all of her students
that we come from
all walks of life.
-My mom raised me
as a single mother.
She's always worked really hard
to provide a really good
life for me just by herself.
She decided she wanted to
go back to school.
She was substitute teaching
and said,
"I want to do better and provide
better for these kids."
And here she is today,
a teacher of 4th grade
in a low-income school district,
and she's great at it.
She's also helping my cousin
raise her son with her
so she can go to school.
And now I'm gonna cry.
But she is awesome.
[ Voice breaking ] She's the
best mom anyone could ask for.
-Hi. Good morning.
-Hi, how are you doing?
Thanks for coming in.
-Thanks for having us.
-So we're just gonna record some
lines for this NBC special.
So they're on the prompter.
Whenever you're ready.
And...action.
-Hi, I'm Susan from
Long Island City, New York.
-And I'm Joanne from Astoria.
-And we want to wish
all the amazing moms watching
a happy Mother's Day.
-Samsung heard all about me
and wants to thank me
for all I do as a mother
and teacher
by gifting me a Samsung Galaxy
Mother's Day bundle of products.
Whoa!
Thank you.
[ Gasps ]
-Surprise!
-Oh, my God!
[ Applause ]
-Oh, I'm gonna --
-Happy Mother's Day!
How are you?
-Good. I can die.
-We wanted to celebrate you,
Samsung wanted to celebrate you.
So on top of all this,
we also have a check
for $25,000.
-Oh, my goodness.
[ Applause ]
Thank you so much.
-Here, I can hold something.
-We'll definitely share this
with our school.
-Hi, I'm Kayla from
Victorville, California.
-And I'm Shelley
from Victorville, California.
-And we want to wish all
the amazing moms watching
a happy Mother's Day.
-Samsung heard all about me
and wants to thank me
for all I do as a mother
and teaching
[ Voice breaking ]
by gifting me
a Samsung Galaxy Mother's Day
bundle of products.
What?
-Oh.
-Oh. What --
-Surprise!
[ Applause ]
-Oh, my gosh!
-How are you?
-Wonderful!
-Samsung wanted to do
something even more for you,
as a mom and as a teacher,
so we'd like to give you
a check for $25,000.
[ Applause ]
It's for you.
-Oh, my God.
Thank you everybody, so much.
-Thank you.
[ Crying ]
-Happy Mother's Day.
-We want to wish all
of the amazing moms watching
a happy Mother's Day.
-Samsung heard all about me
and wants to thank me
for all I do as
a mother and teacher.
Oh, my God.
-Surprise!
-Ahh!
[ Screaming ]
[ Applause ]
-What's up? Come on!
Give me that!
Come on! Hi!
-[ Screaming ]
-[ Laughing ]
Happy Mother's Day.
Look at what you have
You have every Samsung Galaxy.
You have the tablet.
You have the watch.
The earbuds. You've got
the phone, the S22 Plus.
You're set!
-I am.
And I met Jimmy Fallon!
-And you met me! Come on.
But you're a great mom
and you're a great teacher
and you're a great person,
and everyone loves you.
And Samsung wants to give you
one more thing,
if you don't mind.
Here's a check for $25,000.
-No!
-Here you go. A giant check.
Haven't you always wanted
a giant check?
How's it feel? How's it feel?
-I -- I --
I don't know.
-My family said no crying on TV.
And I'm breaking that rule.
-No, it's alright.
Happy Mother's Day!
-Happy Mother's Day!
♪♪
-Great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you to Samsung for
helping us out with that.
Thank you to Joanne, Rosa,
and Shelley.
They're in our audience
right now.
Where are you guys?
[ Cheers and applause ]
In there somewhere.
There you are,
somewhere back there.
Thank you to all the incredible
moms and teachers out there.
That was fun.
You'd think the bundle
was fun enough,
and then this double surprise.
And I'm not --
-Giant check.
-Yeah, giant --
I'd love to get a giant check.
That's so fun, right?
-Come on.
-It's like a dream come true.